whoa the intro did not play hello that
was not as intended but anyways hey
what's up guys black out beta is live
called duty if you guys didn't know what
that is that's basically Call of Duty's
battle royale we're just gonna hop right
into it I haven't actually played a
match yet and I'm guessing my picture
and picture is actually not in a good
spot but hey let's figure this out
together huh so here's black out I guess
you can only play as as a quad team can
I change that no I'm kind of oh there's
your zombie stuff you can personalize
your character kind of sure alright
let's just do it let's just deploy well
we'll deploy well figure it out it don't
matter I move myself real quick nope
can't do it there sorry for the like
just like early random kind of stream
but I mean normally we're live at 11
a.m. but you know obviously with
blackout coming out figured we'd go live
early for obvious reason we're gonna
have to mute some people even though you
probably don't want to meet people bring
out down the gameplay for now just
because I don't want to have those guys
as audio push through but I'll bring
back audio cannot meet these guys this
is awkward
alright we're deploying in seconds yeah
we're in the party mind my dude I need
to mute you but I can't wait going yeah
where are we going good question mute
[Music]
meet all except party that's not gonna
do it huh
I'm here to support you so scram thank
you
nice tumor interview yeah that's this
morning right what's up whoa look at all
these helicopters holy crap where are we
going though do we got a new town wait
what those nuketown Oh new towns on the
island oh that's some that's some stuff
firing range I guess we're going to air
it array my teammate wants us to go to
array Oh I muted everyone sick okay good
I don't need to hear them right no we
find our wingsuiting out
I think I'm dropping yeah I'm dropping
too array right now cuz my teammates are
dropping over a some guy died already
oh you drop really fast I'm alright pick
this up oh you can pick up backpacks
just I got a tacher nade
I got a brawler perk I guess gun dude
this is weird this is really weird okay
okay like I can't tell like what I can
and can't all right we got to find like
an AR or something this is so weird to
like this is so weird
okay yes you're not seeing it right now
I've been sending it so are you at the
RT okay he walked away okay that's a
different backpack sorry I was talking
to a co-worker who says they can't see
it on on Twitter but it should be there
my man gag I all right we're in the
circle this is better than for Nightside
how do you know have you played oh
that's a bad guy that's a bad guy 100
percent of bad guy oh he did not die
from those three hit markers we got any
as an AR all right we got him we got him
we got him we got Wu Tang all right
let's see what it looks like all right
we got his oh he has a Hellion salvo to
shoot give me our Maddox all right that
guy had some goodies oh we got to get
this a K though huh
[Music]
okay skulker I don't know what that is
consumer how many of these perks can we
have I don't even get it right now oh
you got scopes oh we got scopes guys
look a sniper I don't even dare to
sniped all right I will dare to sniper
Derrick's night well there his name I'm
not a good sniper I'm just gonna say
that up front now oh is that the
swordfish oh but my scope how do we take
this go BA take this this scope off
that's why for the swordfish where the
hell did my scope oh wow cluster grenade
do we get to equip the scope oh it's on
my paladin it auto that's fine all right
whenever a guy's died already
I guess nice one Eric and he's go down
fast I don't know man
that seemed kind of slow no Molly we had
just like space for all this stuff
that's sg-12 laser sight my inventory is
full what's quick oh we can quit quit I
don't know use iron lungs
are these like all abilities that you
can use them I don't know I'm just gonna
clip them do I know exactly what I'm
using no oh shoot there all buffs that I
just used okay good to know so if you
use your buffs you can use multiple
buffs hold trauma kit
alright so oh no that's not what I
wanted to do I read that wrong okay
clipped it needs alright okay so we can
pick some more stuff up now after I
reload so mixed up up G with
counter-strike hum maybe so I'm not
seeing it here I don't know what to tell
you gauge cuz I'm sending it dude are
you sure you're using the same program
she has like a different Twitter
producer thing so you might want to hit
her up if she's available just got here
do you drop I'm playing yes they're
technically like helicopters and you
wingsuit down except when you wingsuit
down it's a lot faster so yeah we killed
someone we stole his his stuff he had
decent stuff went the circle okay it's
slowly closing looks like there's
vehicles as there should be just Supply
Drop inbound no idea where it's coming
from I hear gunfire yeah you could drive
that thing
Oh oh crap there's two people there's
two people ya body armor which is not
fair he's a cheater don't go over there
man oh shoot I'm hella low on my pot
alright bottomless look my life
oh I knocked him come on Mac Daddy you
can do it I'm being revived that's good
okay so we took out that other team
right it looks like we took out that
other team me and Mac Daddy all right
I'm a 200 light now he's got a coschka
all right so not bad yeah for tonight's
dead I don't know man that's missing no
maybe I just don't feel like hello pick
it up thank you
oh he's got a car okay we're in the
circle which is obviously a good thing
smoke is probably
but then pick it up obviously I really
should just go like auto rifles and not
bother sniping because I'm not great at
sniping the circle is here what do you
want to go macdaddy you doing good
why won't you pick up this first aid I
got to hold it with my bed hold down
square guys apparently we got brawler
can use mobility and I know what
consumer does but good should be looting
more houses 27 alive got 2 kills in my
name if I didn't try to go for that down
and actually fought the other guy I
think we would have been ok to be honest
I should I should remember that going
forward use your scope on your sniper
dude yeah I probably should
that's a good shout I can not hide in
this bush because that's not a thing all
right all right two times is on the
sniper now the F is this game is this
this is the black out sorry black out
called duty battle royale basically it
is the beta full game comes out in
October so I'm saying this looks better
than pub G it looks better than pub G at
least compared to the Xbox one version
that's for dang sure that game did not
run this runs pretty well so far haven't
had any hitches or anything weird trauma
kit seems like it used an additional 50
life on top of the 150 that you normally
have not sure how that one guy got body
armor but here's the hoping we can find
some body armor perhaps
oh wow censored art so how does that
work that equipment yeah okay cool so
that's the equipment you can have a
censored art which is pretty cool
okay it's r1 and I get three shots with
it
it's still really drunk and weird to
freaking open doors like this and call
it like it's a better Oriole even though
yes logically all that makes sense
out to time scope and another censored
art we're still in the circle 18 lux
what did they see what did they see
you're shooting that lawnmower
there's this there's the ship or plane
getting in the passenger seat
dude come back alright in the passenger
seat you can aim and switch seats
apparently
we're all set on Twitch okay cool
Twitter brother Jesus thank you guys all
for tuning it oh that's a guy alright
nice we killed that guy further collapse
expected travel to indicated safe zone
nothing
nattie riches up there oops
alright cool um Oh circle is getting
smaller we gotta get to snick spot in a
second where's that last guy was like I
wonder if there's bots that's that's a
good question is like do they fill games
with BOTS or is it all like real people
I guess you could tell by gamer tags all
right we're skirting the outside here
that call Supply Drop incoming
should try to get to a Supply Drop too
huh
some point circle collapsed eminent get
to safety
what do you prefer bro pub G for tonight
our OS or lockout I don't know
first game my first game on blackout I
personally between four night buggy I
liked for tonight a little bit better
but that's my personal opinion I might
end up liking this more just because I
like Cod shooting mechanics more but
again this first game so no idea five
six five six so we'll see it's also very
interesting right now I mean like the
game's new or well not that Cod's new
but this mode isn't you always hated the
building we can't yeah I wasn't good at
it so like this might help me because I
don't have to like worry about the
building so so much and then we can just
worry about like you know good
old-fashioned Cod fighting what's
interesting is I haven't really seen any
more of those like perks that we got in
the beginning of the game like I haven't
seen them in other buildings which is
weird obviously because you would think
that Oh make it that's good because you
would think that you would see like a
bunch of on foot I do not see any we're
almost in a top 10 situation there's
three of us that means there's seven
other opponents right now that we need
to deal with we are in the circle as
mentioned which is good I'm kind of
running around willy-nilly and it's
probably a bad idea it's just I don't
know I don't know exactly what else to
do in a card game you know it's what I
do
running gun yak is a better way oh I
don't know about that
rip pub gee I don't know maybe hard to
say I did say I haven't sang on for a
while now as as we've known that this
game was coming out that there was a
good chance that this could be all
there's a helicopter that this could be
the third like battle royale game to get
into the fields and be very predominant
or you
oh my god do I dare to pilot this I am
so scared to pilot that I'll be in the
passenger yeah you fly us out of here
dude we're gonna get salvo though man
I'm scared I'm scared I don't know and I
don't know if yeah yeah you you go Batum
with the with the helicopter and then
hope that they don't have rockets I
guess I should have gotten that I should
have gone in there huh he brush camp not
really all right you guys go for it
between the three of us
we'll hear them from land and air we got
a hope that they don't have it if they
don't have a rocket
we'll be okay but as we saw in that
first guy that guy had a rocket I just
didn't take it now I'm thinking like
what if rocket or like what if anti-air
is like part of the meta and you
actually need one so boring sorry well
we haven't ran into anyone yeah and the
circle is closing
oh he just jumped out oh he's dead oh
he's so dead I'm gonna try to revive him
I guess you can't jump out you don't get
a wingsuit that's good to know it's not
like for tonight I guess you don't just
get a you don't just get your thing to
over five times really fast though huh
or feels like it you know you don't get
to just jump out and like fly around
that's not how that works I wonder if
the pilot can even fire anything oh I
hear gunfire oh here you go there's a
finally another perk thing
maybe they're shooting at our helicopter
while I aleut so far I only seen two
time scopes okay I gotta remember that I
have an SM or pulse that pulse burst
rifle and not uh full they are so if we
get stuck in close quarters that the
sniper might be a bad thing for me all
right nine left did that guy have a man
bun I don't know he's a noob maybe but
like the game looks sick by the way
can't watch this anymore in nowhere he's
classy sorry this is part of battery
although I'm looking for folks to fight
get that dinner with Rezanov I'm gonna
try to get that dinner I don't even know
what it's called it would be nice to win
the first match whatever that is
whatever that ends up being called what
do you think they call it like a cod
Royale
further collapse expected traveled to
indicated safe zone we're pretty much in
the circle so they gotta come to us oh
sorry
circle is like you're in front of us
rather this guy's playing it smart
he's like crouch walking I'm just
running around like a idiot get to
safety
all right looks like the circles are
closing sooner as they should I know it
Outlander does
fired a long-range sensor Dart
oh I didn't mean to do that I'm so sorry
guys I thought it was three shots that I
could I wasted a cluster grenade that
sucks I have no idea where these guys
are
should I go after the supply job I guess
so huh oh there there there there there
they're all fighting in that room how
did that miss I should not picked up the
sniper I lied it worked out it worked
out worked out circles in front of us
excuse me
sit Rep circle collapse imminent get to
safety
oh my teammates are still here there is
only six people left which means there's
three opponents to our three-on-three
here all right I'm in the circle I know
there's one guy that oh shoot long I
just got smoked I've no idea where he
got shot from either there's a problem I
hear footsteps oh he has a war machine
oh that's so dirty that's so dirty
why does he have a war machine oh my god
that sucks my teammate leaves we did
some oh yeah our squad did it
I think our squad did it cuz it says
number one wait is that us though no I
don't think that was us I don't think
that was this I can't tell
unfortunately all right we'll try again
as a decent person I actually got three
or four kills we're on ps4 either the
map too big or not enough players per
map it's hard to say
Beamer it could depend on where the
drops what's a war machine um that was
like this the alt ability of battery
where she has a grenade launcher so I
got grenade launcher essentially which
is unfortunate but you know I still
killed that person I guess at the end of
the day but that was unfortunate oh all
right I just entering the staging area
so here's the map we dropped that array
last time you only see your fireteam or
your team here I guess you don't see the
other people or you only see some people
weird
see here's my question right like if
these are all other people right like
how come it doesn't seem like it was
like 979 people in here playing BOTS see
really what's the deal upgraded version
of funky sure now I want to play and
optimize pop G yeah over there I've seen
like maybe like 18 verse all right not
eight other people here that weren't
part of my team
I know it's weird
hey what's the max player for room right
now 8 this one has a tee forget the
exact number says victory huge after the
end of the game and he goes I don't
think we want stupid well I wasn't sure
Patrick because I spectated someone so I
wasn't sure if it was like my team that
actually want because I definitely died
so I don't know if my my teammate got
the win or not they put you in random
places on the map not just there okay
that's fair we don't care about seeing
you bro I'm at the beginning just got
here well I'm gonna leave it up for now
unless the picture picture really messes
with people but looks like we going here
guess we're going to River Thames
you're team one okay thanks it would
have been nice to see like him get the
last kill I didn't spectate soon enough
you're Scott you're spot gets the win
bro okay
thanks sorry I mean apologies first game
I'm that's kind of sick actually to win
our first game I shouldn't have come in
here with you I'm sorry any a backpack
oh there's our detected advisory
location to indicate it safe zone hey
please answer me black out for a black
ops four or fortnight I think it's up to
you
Oh level three armor could you imagine
if we actually had our more just now I
think it's up to you I think there's
gonna be a lot of people playing black
black out though to be honest it's like
if you like Call of Duty and you like
bad or al this might be up your alley
you really use an AR
it sounds no AR is huh up question a
swordfish
well Tory's fool
you're good fire circle collapse eminent
get to safety
I need a backpack really bad
you have that pack yes yes we got a
backpack can't open it okay there whoa
Titan co-operators smokes look at that
thing
we're taking that I guess seems like an
insane gun I guess I don't know we'll
take it it had a lot of it had a lot of
mods on it for attachments rather it's
just a PlayStation 4 now that's correct
now I don't know how I feel about the
LMG LMG Plus oh did we just kill someone
I'm guessing all of that practice
is this the hammer
who says it looks boring might as well
call the John report yeah I mean like
part of its just like I have to I have
to farm loot and gear and stuff like
that so I'm sick of battle royale games
well it's a good thing about at least
Cod is with black ops war is that bad
guy I saw something moving is that
there's you know your normal traditional
multiplayer and then you have also you
also have zombies they're gonna have
like three zombie stories right off the
bat
oh that oh I wish I had a thing to shoot
that helicopter down I'd be hilarious
actually a lot of people are dying now
we got to figure out like what what is
the cod equivalent of tilted towers like
that's what we got to find out
probably should have gotten that thing
with them that buggy oh can I not get
into it's only a two person
trying to shoot the helicopter and
there's a buggy over there let's try to
roll up on those guys I guess we'll
flank them I don't I guess maybe swim
we'll find out nuketown maybe this looks
promising it's just beta yeah it's it's
a lot crisper than I thought it would be
oh [ __ ] I took color damage underwater
shoot there in that house though I don't
know if they saw me travel to indicate
it safe zone well I see you do just go
that's my fault for it speaking too long
yeah we're dead
I tried to get the flank for you guys
and died for it that was a not as good
as the first time I guess their way to
bleed out I just quit the game LMAO
hitmarkers yeah I just I whipped a lot C
can change a character to either one of
the specialists or it looks like there's
blackout characters that you can get to
you
go to Newtown please all right you got
James I will try to go to any town
probably gonna get roasted
let's get spicy and see if Newtown is
the way to go yeah
Isaiah you got Perez you got a good
point it's just game mode who really
cares it's like a Mack because they have
TDM yeah I mean you're either gonna
played or you're not right so that's my
fault I just know I missed a lot so this
is like the starting area I guess you
can get grappled on so the thing is you
can get the abilities that are like you
know on certain operators and stuff like
that is why that person probably had the
war machine earlier
see that boats the place to actually
kill them maybe or night
are there any story LMS is mode as right
now not they know what this is just the
beta so many more people in this area
than there was that last area we're in
this is gonna be a standalone this mode
is is something you can play as part of
the game yeah infiltrate engage and
destroy oh my god well that case we were
just in there like lobby so
we're gonna go in Newtown because that's
where everyone wants me to go so
hold your butt's I guess
my whole team dropped out of silent
whatever
we'd be hilarious we like kind of go
I'm gonna die aren't I
okay there's definitely people going -
nuketown I hope it's not a team because
I'm by myself oh I am I'm really screwed
guys now this is like pub G right now Oh
No
okay alright don't need first aid right
now
sitrep potential collapse their guns in
this little case indicated safe zone is
advised there he has a gun I'm pretty
sure oh there's a gun
vapenation I'd like some farmer anything
my loved one
oh there's three times
you know I surprisingly
it's not that many people here I guess
no I saw it hang it I was like I saw mom
I swear
well it was worth a try guys it's to
pass fast pace for about or a you think
so I think it's fine
can you show the inventory screen yeah
I'll do that in a second on one uh
welcome guys my fault
let's see Call of Duty 4 battlefield 5
hard to say caches I think it depends I
think most people like have one of those
two games this is a game that they play
battlefield did get delayed though to
November trying to watch chat sorry guys
run riding solo today it's a busy Monday
but uh asylum my dude so here's the
inventory screen here's all your ammo
your health stuff some gear storage
equipment when you have storage your
backpack you get 10 slots where are we
now oh we're in a silent
with a firefight whoa there's delay the
hell Oh out of bullets
we this was very cool I like this the
asylum show the characters when you get
a chance man I did show the characters
earlier
it looks flushed out yeah it's pretty
pretty good so far anyway to make
yourself louder you might be just set
the game's loud probably thank you for
that hopefully this isn't too loud but
if Felix if this is too much tell me
later when is PC Bay alive that I'm not
sure if I don't know if they have
announced that yet black out
where should we go guys should we drop
with our teammates find zombies can try
I don't know where they'd be at though
teammates where we going where we going
where we going nobody's calling us by
guess we're going a firing range one guy
just straight dropped to asylum where
he's going to turbine I don't know where
he's going
oh crap
don't want to be on the open down here I
guess so I got fracking nade
oops Oh so here's an inventory essential
get some gear and stuff wow it's a weird
a circle for the first circle I got the
hustle later you get some body armor
backpacks ooh there's a 9 bang what the
hell is a 9 bang 9 bang is essentially a
like really strong flashbang stun
grenade
it's what man for game is a operator
named axel
scope with us right now scope in a
backpack still time
we try to kill someone for bad guys
going through the crop field here like
field here with like the firing range
going through the farm it has no loop
like a lot of actually around it'll
collapse I'm gonna get to safety
we lost one of our dudes the sight on it
we lost two of our dudes my guys in a
boat right now I don't know where they
got the boats going but no didn't want
to swap did you escape
I'm so stupid
net coal supply drop incoming
yet no scopes
all right
nice hair TV no I'm gonna do that we're
swim that nine bang did not do what I
thought it would do
I also panicked like crazy so I don't
know I guess I'll whatever I'm gonna go
for a little swim
there's also supply drops to all those
saying that the graphics is crap if you
have a high and PC yeah who knows we
haven't seen PC yet this is technically
not final and if you can argue that to
but yeah
a lot of gunfire
what do you guys think that one guy went
that I was shooting dipped
well there's a boat there that my team
is shooting it I don't think they stayed
at the dock though
so much better fire right now be advised
further collapse expected relocate to
safe zone
are you crapping me right now at that
safe zone lit up here we gotta go we're
so far from that circle well we got two
minutes though
28 left thanks everyone for tuning in
appreciate it appreciate your patience
as we're kind of running around a lot
sorry that I haven't really seen too
many folks to fight and I didn't get
that head showing on that one guy there
so my apologies funny thing is didn't we
just come from over here okay here we go
is this a bad idea probably my dude is
over there I know what he's doing he's
healing I'm trying to get to the circle
talk like some stuff though maybe trauma
kit
take the buggy it's just you and me five
for the would ask pedal gas pedal
that is square right
sit Rep circle collapsible to get to
safety
dude I got hit by that oh my god is this
like fortnight all or is it for tonight
yeah it's like for tonight all over
again where you get like hit by the
freaking thing oh crap a hair car see
that guy
basically that I jumped out and the
vehicle rolled over me luckily luckily
it didn't kill me
all right so easy killer see here's the
problem right like going through these
these things right here right would be
like this is where you like probably die
like this guy just died
right like you would just die there
right because you can't go through it
fast enough that might be where PC has
an advantage is if you can actually swap
and look through loot faster then
someone this is a Forex scope I'll see
what other equipment attachments I have
but I'm kind of scared right now all
right so I don't have any other
attachments other than the optics for
this thing sadly well we could keep
farming what happens outside the server
I would assume you just bleed out or
take damage from the circle should we
just take the trauma kit
I haven't sure how to do that there you
go up on the d-pad then it was expected
trouble to indicate it safe zone right
outside hope that's a person when do I
have out you see me oh you totally saw
me feels bad should not have pushed
there can you loot with the inventory
open and we can try there's a guy
straight ahead yeah is my fault y'all
that was my fault
sure just trauma I think if I use my
trauma kit there I would have been fine
cuz I wouldn't have pushed into those
guys
I shouldn't have put myself out in the
open either
it's stupid real stupid real stupid
again thank you guys all for tuning in
to gain spot live we go live Monday to
Friday usually at 11 a.m. Pacific time
but sometimes we start early especially
if there's a new fun mode like blackouts
which is Call of Duty's battle royale
out and about so we're checking it out
came out at 10 a.m. Pacific today on the
PlayStation 4 first not sure about PC
beta because people are gonna ask you
need some trusty teammates yeah probably
Zane Rosine Roman that's right how we
want that first game was because our
team actually stayed together whereas
like I've been kind of staying with
people and kind of not oh we can drop a
new town let's go new town the trailer
lied how so
all right we're going to Newtown
this is 30 euro right no it's $60 for
the whole game I would assume Sun stereo
would rather have a campaign than
blackout I'm just not gonna not gonna
not gonna knock it he's gonna get a gun
before me I'm gonna die to that guy
though I did not see him dropping to be
honest scope to guns even get armor that
cluster grenade not killing what did you
just run oh well played
I did get outplayed damn he had he had
frickin thing he had bought armor and I
guess I didn't headshot him fast enough
that sucks
I thought for sure I'd get him but don't
know we didn't ask for this
well like I said there's three different
versions you can like three different
modes or more no that's not true
you can play traditional multiplayer
which has a lot of different multiplayer
modes if you want you can play the
blackout which is like their battle
royale or you can play zombies if none
of those interests you guys you don't
have to play call of duty like that's
the beauty of video games everyone you
have options I scrubbed it up there
apologies
elusive says he's gonna get more
entertainment out fallout 76 that's
awesome do that well they sell blackout
mode separately I don't think so doing
Saint John I don't think so so for sure
there's a good amount of people that
seem to want to go to like nuke out or
it could just be like depending on the
path you're taking it could be like
wherever like the first part is that
could be like you know where all the
people go I think it's a T nor Bella's I
can tell the pacing is good you can play
more than two rounds a day oh you can
play a bunch of rounds if you wanted to
depending on how you know risky you want
to play how what she wants to quit the
teammates you know it just depends
because you know you could either have
to you can farm a bunch you can run or
not like we can drop lighthouse I don't
think I want to drop lighthouse though
like oh wait one of my teammates dropped
the lighthouse well good luck to him
looks like we're going to fire range
I'll go to firing
I can hit people in the helicopter
that's awkward
that noise you're hearing is me hitting
people in the helicopter or at least
hitting our three what do you die before
the game actually starts you dive into
like the staging area which is
interesting for sure that's a new town
after it got blown up
probably more polish than pub G I mean
it feels better than the pub G on Xbox
one that's for sure at least in my
opinion
I'm not sure if I like that looting
system but oh yeah where's my team at we
drop firing range what happened
it killed this friend though or well
whoever the other guy was Oh character
screen here you go so here's all the
operators damn it
that was all the zombie people well they
have multiple maps try not in a way they
can they argue that you're getting
multiple maps because like each area is
like kind of like multiple maps but yeah
this looks great says urban legend yeah
it feels good so far pochi barely runs
on xbox one yeah that's kind of why it's
easy comparison to make is there a solo
mode or is it just glides right now Cory
it's just squads my guess is I wouldn't
be shocked if there's like solo mode in
the future but yeah they're at
lighthouse lol no I only saw one guy
drop lighthouse the other two guys
definitely dropped firing range with me
but they might have been alluding you
know so
it's very possible that they were
looting some guns have attachments some
seem to have them we're ready James Lin
on them and then others you just you
have to add your own add-ons no campaign
story there's no campaign story that we
know let's see oh one guy dropped
already guessing on cargo docks Hey look
like Legos from up here you can't win
this solo everyone is in a squad too
long to kill yeah Chris I didn't mean to
like run into those those those guys oh
you can get a helicopter here though
that's pretty good so yeah I mean like I
ended up having to fight them at that
point right we didn't win our first
match surprisingly but it was due in
mostly because we did stay with our team
and our team actually you know because
it's the first game you kind of kind of
take it slower trying to learn the map
and the game and stuff like that like
whereas we got two guys I just went off
on their own willy-nilly and they're now
at the 3x we didn't get a gun and get
get back up there I came here because I
got the indicator to come here and oh
wait no we got two guys here 4x scope 3x
scope pick up all the ammo before it's
detected relocation to indicates it's
safe zone as advised oh we're in this
circle that worked out
so there's also like those perks that
you can use essentially like equip or
use for a limited time I don't know them
all so I kind of just spammed them the
first game we played to be honest
oops doors semi right
all right backpacks good has mentioned
backpack lets you pick some more stuff
up
I want the quartet are the Matt on okay
there's someone here boys gang shot from
like the other roof health pack no idea
what I like he's up top somewhere
there's body armor as well
oh just about Derek OC you like some of
these guns already have like everything
on it so like this thing this this must
feel like a equivalent of a gold tier
gun or something that makes sense
hey finding like a legendary or whatever
on the ship Oh
trauma kit yeah we'll get the 200 with
this circle collapse I'm gonna get to
safety no good hard alright recon car
right
are all the kids jumping because that's
what you do in cod you jump shoot and
stuff
really wish anywhere these folks were to
drop something they're actually you know
what hopefully no one sees me here
wish I knew where they were when the
circle though we were definitely getting
shot though at
grapple gun
so update 2x is probably better
not that this SMG even needs it alright
I know my dude is like way far away I
also show her or fallen ill I is
fortunately try to get to my teammate
cuz teamwork makes the dream work are
you playing duo's right now no it was
squads and it was just us two that are
left over our one player one of our
players went to asylum on his own got
killed [ __ ] that's serpentine shot from
behind obviously in the old shake and
bake I wish I could understand that if
my guy kill him why not right Oh an ABR
but since we have that sniper ready
it's like we're setting up shop here so
just chill here I guess
when the circle
maybe you did kill that guy that was
shooting me
oh my god you're gonna cross the bridge
it seems risky Oh your legs yeah old
tango I haven't found anyone to fight so
part of that's my fault I guess we're
trying to leave
but part of its just Battle Royale
is it okay if I share this on Twitter of
course you can share the stream on
clubbers expected in the cage it's safe
so appreciate you asking that today's
the last day for battlefield beta yeah
I think that mechanics of this are
better than the h10 z1r a aldo for the
person saying like you might as well
play h1z1 oriale whoa okay so that's my
opinion
try to be good to get some first aid huh
okay to that point
there's so much gunfire
there's a factor where we died earlier
you know that feeling when like you guys
probably see someone and then I don't oh
there's a person
shoot them though so he'll collapse a
minute get to safety
try to lead it mist control here there's
a pipe but I'll be bound
Factory
you would think one of them would go
loot this body
maybe they don't care and they're
smarter to the night
there's definitely people there though
my teammates chillin
he's gonna go into that room where a
bunch of people fighting
Oh Jane toys what oh my gosh on the
worst in the world you now knows I'm
here like shot them sick
someone's here my teammate died
it's unfortunate I didn't mean that
whatever oh wait Jane oh he's still
alive I lied
I panicked by the way I'm not really
good sniping stop apologies I know
be advised further collapse expected
relocate the safe zone
why did I peek no leaning function now
it's God let's see if our team made
still alive years all right do oh wow
this guy's oh no he's got three kills I
was like Oh
there's no lien that I know
and do we spectate guys or do we get out
of here I missed a couple of snapshots
that's bad oh thanks Nick
sometimes you just gotta be honest with
yourself and I'm honest with myself
disappointing yeah I know sorry deaf kid
I should have just chilled up top longer
I'm just gonna believe that this guy is
not gonna win it I'm gonna play a game
instead unfortunate unfortunate
unfortunate which car would do
leaning function maybe sir anyone yeah
your wish you play good then that IGN
guy though what does that mean at then
the IGN guys good or is what I mean the
if it's James Duggan he's pretty solid
at shooter games excuse me
it's alright Nick I mean thanks for
stopping by
thanks for keeping it real with me
appreciate
excuse me - that bad Royale is boring as
helll says do well it's it's free nah
it's not for everybody obviously so you
know for the people that want to play it
or want to play Cod in a different way
this is one of those ways right so is
this a separate download from the last
beta mine did a preload during the
weekend but if you had the beta it's
like an additional I want to say like 14
gigs is what it added at least from what
I recall seeing on a Friday so
is this baby going to be open at some
point or is it free or only that I don't
know I'm not gonna say that Isaiah but
if that's how you feel that's fine I'm
okay with that
sorry I'm not okay with that rather is
whatever that's good this guy face palm
into the ground by the way Erik won his
first game I mean yeah that was a better
it does a much better game for sure one
of our guys has trade drops and the rest
of us look like they want to go to okay
we want a parent okay yeah we'll go to
we'll go there
that's bartering like going past buying
range okay think so people are getting
their real hot though alright people are
being nice down there which is very bad
bad news for us there's a guy going to
the gas station ready or what appears to
be the gas station hi hi I like a weapon
in this shop that appears to have melee
weapons hanging kind of try to heal and
jus come man there should be like we
just got lucky
bad building bad building why don't MPC
why don't battle Royales games and
corporate NPCs for you to kill in
between fights that's a good question do
there are supposedly zombies on this map
that you can kill that have like good
loot or something like that so Beamer 99
says hello how did games Rocky's shadow
a Tomb Raider at six in IGN and I'm so
confused
that's just how I think it was edy
right I'm in transit reviewed it that's
how he felt about the game so you know
everyone's gonna have different opinions
obviously from what I can tell though
some of the folks on video at least that
I know we're playing the game that have
played the previous two games as well
did did say that they weren't you know
that it was still good but it wasn't
like as good as the last two I think
from what I recall them saying but don't
quote me on that that's just the stuff I
hear in the office or at least from a
couple people not the office just a few
but yeah it's basically differing
opinions
I did the tumor yeah the old heal and
you get you every time yes it didn't
work I should have just tried the Juke
instead of healing Rowley hey sir
looks like porn out with the realistic
graphics sure no building now the time
to kill here takes a while in my opinion
can't say for sure yet until I play
tonight but just seems that way yeah the
time to kill is definitely not that
quick six skin sick sins and also
because you can get different tiers of
body armour you can as mention what the
trauma kit have fifty extra life so you
know especially if they have body armor
it's definitely going to take a little
bit longer the time to kill is
definitely going to be longer for sure
looks like we're going to a construction
site which I'm totally down for just
because it's at the end of the run we
can pick up a lot of gear probably and
get back to the middle I'm streaming as
well let's play dude this game rocks
have fun Tommy I mean if we happen to
get in the same lobby cool
we need ARMA for maybe
of course thanks everyone for tuning in
again to our call of duty blackout
stream which is Call of Duty's new
battle royale mode we won our first game
shockingly and then haven't done so hot
since but I feel good about this
this one only just because our team is
together and I found a gun right away
which is always nice to guns even oh no
one of our guys is dead but I wouldn't
be shocked if he kind of just like ran
off on his own scope detected relocation
indicated safe zone is advised that
barricade razor-wire we can really like
camp it out possibly way hear gunfire
see this is another one of those
examples of like one of those like sort
of like legendary type of guns I think
because it's got all like the mods and
everything are per attachments yeah
someone just gotta kill Nicole supply
drop incoming you really want I just use
my trauma kit but to do that I have to
do like that
yeah that was a long time to kill there
and he melted my armor so we need new
body armor for sure
sitrep circle collapse imminent get to
safety oh crap we gotta go it's pretty
far oh no wow did not break my legs
somehow
I gotta move right I guess we don't have
to yet because that friend request for
scope the does immediate though huh
cushion
how're we gonna get there oh that time I
broke my legs so now barricade number 2
DX is probably better I feel like we
gotta go though while these two guys are
still like looting their hearts
let's go boys frakking Tower oh I got a
vehicle she's good and get there on the
hurry just a mistake to go by myself
probably
Cory wants a co-op campaign is what they
feels like it would have been nice if
they did ad
it's weird that like when I hit back
baby you Lee look back or she looks back
now dude had a helicopter that's why he
wasn't worried about it nice
oh they just took out my helicopter guy
God he's all me
that's a team for sure
okay revive him oh I can't buy a mistake
water your way this way here at car
though
my team is bound to come out all right
we got to go though
circles closing in if I take some damage
here that's fine no nevel here further
collapse expected travel to indicate
it's safe zone sure snipe that first guy
huh
here a lot of gunfire
you gotta take the ridge right oh now
Navi lived doing here drop this guy
heels or something
we're zombies they're supposed to be
like zombies on the map so my dad I need
to drop this guy he'll though for first
AIDS he needs to come back over here
though oh wait can you get hit by your
team - we let that guy run all the way
back down the hill are you kidding oh oh
we're gonna chop from behind that's what
it was
do you need get on the other side of
this building or we broken it or
whatever that's fine I'll just die for
it you killed you
okay nice night buddy my teammate Supply
Drop inbound
you gotta go
definitely a guy there's two guys on
that Ridgeline
drop heels for this guy
alright drop it though there's some
first aid in here noise I get that scope
back no huh
Oh rockets okay be advised further
collapse expected were you locating to
safe zone 117 we gotta go oh please be
ours oh here it is
I'm gonna stay in there
I gotta come out or is he just scouting
with this stupid
now he wants to come
sitrep circle collapse imminent get to
safety
there's way too many guns laying around
no it's a big old car of
I didn't want to leave that guy but he
is gonna make this swim across I think
that call supply drop incoming it's just
you and me fight for the win
seriously Wow please
one guy knocked can't tell I know as I
miss like a bunch of snapshots collapse
expected travel to indicate it's safe
zone
Jesus how many trucks can we miss like
everyone I'm never I'm never picking up
a sniper again I tried I tried crouching
just now trip of I and just not I've
just never been good at sniping god why
you gave to murder six that was that was
the don't you snipers bruh yeah I know
she deserved to die for what you did to
your team hey he made it he made it man
I do I do agree though I deserve to die
for missing that many shots though I
hundred percent agree about that
hashtags justice served yes I know uh
it's fun it's soul it's still the same
you see damages still about the same
that's a hard fail bad this this guy is
bad yeah operation Russian I know bad
it's sniping radda sniping
the old bad man
hashtag field that is their bullet drop
it looks like bullet drop yeah I'm
guessing there's will drop because like
I there was a couple where I was like oh
yeah I'm gonna hit it for sure this time
I even made like I made sure to like
slowly put the reticle on him and it
didn't hit so I don't know but like I
said never been good at a sniping so
sorry
imagine quick scoping and one-hit kills
in this mode yeah if you're really good
up close yeah I could see it happening I
am not good at quick scoping or normal
scoping so I'm sorry
that shield oh go rushing hide along the
outskirts more yeah I should instead
don't blame the sniper
oh no I'm saying I'm bad at sniping oh
we're going nuketown I guess we're
probably gonna get it it's probably
gonna be a spicy death gotta lead yo
shots try and try and Robert thank you
though for the advice
honestly I think you're trying to make
some sort of bullet physics adjustment
but in reality it's just Cod and just
don't overcompensate as you're fine okay
thanks
oh we got an auger with them with a
bunch of stuff on it suppressor I think
it's definitely a guy that was in here
or what like looted in there Oh
teammates are down for a teammate gonna
get over to him two teammates are down
now one is just straight dead location
indicated safe zone is advised
there's a guy there and there is sense
don't steal my kill all right we're
doing a lot better right now I guess it
took a legendary auger though which is
like a single shotgun oh yeah
all right so that was some spicy
nuketown for you it's definitely one a
lot better
also there is peeking really outstanding
circle collapse emanate safety not
pressing a button that I don't know that
should probably get going soon
uh-oh I'm ill died over Neil eating
Lotus down one hopefully leading Louis
got the other guy you did okay
told you there is more did that guy just
phase into the world dude where that
lost my teammate why does it look like
oh is he in the water I don't know where
that guy said it looks like he's like in
the ground he's some spaghetti and you
win some spaghetti we just need some
spaghetti I have 5 kills right now
though no no there's probably as good as
it's gonna get for me so far that
looting UI is horrible yeah the it's not
so great I'll be honest it's a little
cumbersome because that's the last thing
you want to do is have to cycle through
that much stuff when you're when you're
on the open right dude make it
you know let's go loading Lotus oh he's
got a trauma kid she's nice
let's go
he went underground there's a bunker
near ah
mr. price you to check that out on
I do agree that looting UI is horrible
yeah it's pretty tough cuz like do you
want to actually do like you know what I
mean do we make do you make that
decision to like loot hoping like it's
gonna be fine or do you just kind of
wait it out I think you probably wait it
out but you know definitely risky
hello
go bro
SiC tricks
eeen seems like it's gonna be tougher
console yeah creed oh crap
but that was such a good that's such a
good little run there that we had in the
beginning standing on that ATV is beyond
dangerous yeah dude I thought he got the
other guy behind the tree there's a
secret bunker in new town with good loot
okay thank you thank you we'll go there
he and dance on the back of the ATV No
have you eaten spaghetti today those
skills I think we just got a good gun in
in the beginning and like we just out
slayed some some folks there but yeah
cycling during you using the d-pad yeah
so I was trying to like wiggle my guy as
I was like sifting through it but it's
hard it's hard still definitely
cumbersome
I don't even I'm not sure if it's better
or worse than the pub GE console looting
because pub G console lootings pretty
bad too because it pulls up like an
actual menu I think outside the quick
stuff just run WTF checkers sorry excuse
me sorry I thought I had that one guy
but and I thought my guy will live long
enough but we shouldn't have maybe he
shouldn't have gone off the ATV right
away but I could see why he did just
because it's like scary I'll try to go
to the bunker later the secret bunker
don't last forget gifts kill sure James
Lane says this that's this you mentioned
answering a lot of questions from
anything some from for this mode awesome
James appreciate I'm glad you're
learning with me and glad that look that
you are Pitt you're being patient with
my my gameplay let's say they want to go
train station though so we tried to go
with my team because it gives us the
best chance of winning obviously I'm
probably only gonna play a few more
matches as we've been live for you know
about two hours but yeah
just FYI five couple more matches see
how we do
so far why are they going the other way
what are you guys going teammates you
called for the train station we're in
the hell are people going dude is that
the trains really that's the train
station that doesn't look so great
punching sound is so bad yeah I'm not
bad I will agree with as well well look
at that blue triangle he's literally
going sideways and why the only one
seeing this are you seeing this okay
he's going to river town now I'm so
confused right now now that guy's going
to hydro dam what is going on dude
please show good game I tried just now I
did my best look too high that's asking
a lot I will do my best though thank you
for your encouragement
give me that chocolates I can try to
make it to River town and hope that my
teammates a little long enough
by the way there's a loosest like the
Box system in here and effect
progression or is it just cosmetic I
have no idea I would I would hope that
it's just cosmetic one of our guys just
died I don't know which one we need a
backpack backpack or armor yeah yeah
like rifle to you that's some razor wire
feel like I'm not using my equipment
enough so that's the one thing I will
say it's just with all this stuff you
can get it's a little bit like
cumbersome at least to start like I mean
obviously it's day one I'm not used to
it muscle memory is not all there for
everything but it is a little awkward at
times I'm not gonna lie because I'm not
using everything like there's all these
skills you can use there's all the
equipment that you can use and I'm just
not using it all in time hopefully
that's something that you know I get
used to or something that's good no med
kits or trauma kits or anything in here
though just unfortunate Oh an AVR why
take the AVR
ramparts pretty good to you I'm not sure
what medic does exactly but these are
still at River town meanwhile Here I am
at the train station oh wait oh I'm at
the hydro dam I'm the idiot I'm the
idiot that didn't even go to train
station yeah yeah I realized that now
mica this is my version of the train
station you know play it off like I know
exactly what I'm doing but yeah that one
guy died by himself feels bad but the
other two did break off and do their own
thing too so you know I wasn't the only
one that went rogue
I don't different backpack unless it
actually matters
they don't actually like have tiers of
backpacks I guess we can not supply drop
incoming
I use paranoia maybe that all their
paranoia like makes stuff on the screen
show up Morris mmm I was hoping to get
some better stuff here
don't feel like the hydro dam is that
great to be honest Scout car
who didn't believe it we should have
just went to like nuke town huh drama
yeah
Oh
you paste jump off the dam who knows I
know that you don't get your thing you
buy yourself where's an enemy
I think nobody drops at the hydro dam so
you wanted someplace to loot come to the
hydro dam
I think everyone's going to like nuke
town and a bunch of other places so I'll
try going to asylum and see if there's
anyone there then maybe we just try to
drop into a new town next game spicy
game or something med kit whatever not
gonna live long enough to use it right
yeah the d-pad like running and I had to
take my hand off the right stick just to
move that d-pad stuff so I could keep
running up my guy died died quick death
click and play with my teammates blue
light and this guy shows you where a
zombie spawn sick thank you for that
like it here its ass see in this island
does he like hella buff cuz I'm hella
scared right now oh oh
level three yeah give me that level
three where's the zombie or is it just
because it has better loot oh there they
are
I guess nothing's free I'm sorry I stole
from your box I'm sorry please forgive
me
here's ambe's see there's so much elude
here holy crap
drop no no in the medic one back no the
old barricade um are there any more
zombo's I hear them that's cool
yes for that tip oh hey got a lot of
light
oh they drop like yes they drop stuff
too
we have a barricade
hey guys we're playing alright so they
definitely drop stuff
someone's scouting me someone someone's
a peeping tom I don't like it
that's cool
some a zombie so many Lutz shot it think
so it's underway that's cool thanks for
that tip
Oh symbol monkey was that do all right
would you like a symbol
i legit need 99 mo oh that's very dark
hi
is there any 99 ammo I had too much fun
killing those zombies that I
oh is that Supply Drop that was a drop
and then I got killed because I went for
it I didn't even get to use the symbol
monkey damn that was cool down
all right so here's the zombie
characters you could pick can't do it
obviously because it's locked
and then here's some of the icons
Rezanov and Menendez Mason and woods
can't pick them either though cuz
they're locked why somebody mecca's it
began dying five bullets and it's more
than that
baited blind yeah was he there did we
miss him did I miss him when he liked
when I made the jump over the fence
probably probably did it's too too
excited by the drop Oh Supply Drop
camper smart monkey summon zombies
alright maybe we go to asylum if it
drops that way oh it's so far though we
could go Newtown who next time throw it
at the Supply Drop yeah it's pretty
smart actually that's a good shout
how do you like the BR for Claude I'm
enjoying it so far it's more that like I
just don't know all the mechanics yet
well so it's kind of just like flying by
the seat of my pants can you fly a
helicopter yes easier to spot people
when you're watching a stream yeah it
happens like I said earlier it's like
one of those feelings where I'm sure you
guys see somebody and I don't you're
just like come on man he's - you're
right I do it all the time - so nuketown
bunker I try to get to the Newtown
bunker and one key Jack's office - where
you toss it expect we'll go to the
Newtown bunker
let's go nuke town guys believe yeah do
you guys want to go to nuke town let's
do it
no one got jumped already guess I'll
jump to you
Oh l2 is fre look
the Newtown bunker is like in that main
building right or somewhere because
that's where the one guy went oh is it
down there it's it over here oh this is
such a mistake isn't it I really hope
this is the bunker
hello pick that up please power one of
our guys is dead take the armor
sitrep potential collapse detected
relocation to indicate it's safe zone is
advised yep this is it
Oh do you see me I was like nope
what just happened
run this way there was definitely an
operator there for a second everyone saw
him right I'm not crazy is the bunker
playing tricks on my mind
hi there
there's a lot of action going on here I
am just in this bunker trying to find my
way out Oh a ladder this is bad isn't it
it's gonna be oh I see you see there's
my ladder are you Wow
can you really troll me by blocking me
here that's hilarious
dude you're just gonna die guy he got me
he got me by blocking the ladder
I was well played by that guy absolutely
well played
yeah Brinsley this is the better
all-round line
black out all right
and where do we go training times over
go to work someone said this will be
free so hundred fifteen to seventeen
where's my team want to go tracking
tower array the firing range
iodine array seems like I recall there's
quite a bit of people at array last time
I don't know what green guys going one
guy's going to hydro dam no idea if
anyone dropped with us
bad guys Oh almost clip through that
wall
yep that's not what I need
double sniper huh wait this is a sniper
yes it is
the dream
this magazine
sitrep potential collapse detected
relocation indicated safe zone is
advised
okay I'm kind of away from the circle
just terrible
don't mind me making all this noise
okay meant to close the door behind me
instead I like opened up even more for
people to see me that's fine let's go to
that zombie huh we have time to do that
yeah that's far always in nuketown isn't
it yeah I don't think I can get there in
time to do that that's kind of far oh
wait it's not that far is at this diner
I was asking can you change fov I don't
think you can change fo VM Consul Canyon
that's weird
is it because now I'm here that like
[ __ ] went away why are you damn bees
here you circle collapsed eminent get to
safety
people collapse emanate I mean here
trying to I'm here trying to fight some
zombies I crazy and that roof everyone
hears I'm right oh well that wasn't
worth
that's the diner from transit right I'm
not sure I'm not super familiar with all
the maps I know array is definitely a
map though in this state is a map we
have a buggy
oh dude pick me up before you go go pick
up chocolate syrup which is totally fine
[Music]
so they're zombies in battle royale mode
too yes and that one place I went to the
asylum I was able to get one of those
like zombie type chests and I was able
to get like level three or five armor or
something like that
she's pretty insane there's a lot of
zombies there they dropped quite a bit
of stuff it was mainly those like things
you activate those like I don't know
perks almost the box was on the roof
[ __ ] alright I kind of figured thanks
squad a Lupe
kind of figured as much I was like I'm
pretty sure there's one every time check
out the options for the fov next time if
you can
zombie randoms they're not so that blue
light ahead of us as mentioned but I
think unknown and some folks in chat
that's where the zombie spawn and so
you'll know that there's a zombie loop
box there as well so it's worth it for
the loop boxes so
sometimes I pay attention to the plants
because check on top of the diner yeah I
should have to be honest I always forget
how slow the first circle is if I can
live long enough I don't think we can
get to that one that one's really far
it's they're very going on blackout I
don't know about that I doubt it
I mean that would be kind of crazy to be
honest but you never know yeah it was
forty-three alive still are there solo
duo squads and squads and SP are
currently in beta
there is only squads
however wouldn't be shocked if come
release that there's uh you know all of
those modes you just mentioned or
versions rather gunfire
oh my god is this the only way out
there's also wonder weapon drops in the
zombie chest or zombie jobs Wow
really
so I guess you can potentially maybe get
the ray gun or something it's 80 players
not 100 for those curious so I guess in
a way we should be trying to like do the
zombies when we can because of those
weapons try to get to my teammates here
helicopter that you don't have a
I'm at ammo and health packs and there
was definitely two of them just now it's
kind of bad news
good booting system we're screwed
Supply Drop inbound sitrep circle
collapse safety 15 seconds oh we are so
dead
man all those games where I had all
those med packs I really wish I had
those med fax right now feels bad I
thought that fall Dan was gonna kill you
uh I kind of I'd like to think like I
wouldn't take 30 fall damage but you
guys like you never know right oh sweet
I don't know force does what I'm hoping
that it gives me some like [ __ ]
armor or something hopefully we can loot
this building over here and get
something that's weird I don't know how
I only have one kill one ice I guess
that guy must have revived his friend
when I sniped them for a friend oh I'm
dead how bad you guys want me
I got one I will do one more real quick
I threw the grenade thinking that come
from that way but ho drive that truck I
should have gotten the truck and left I
actually would have been hilarious to be
honest they all wrapped around ah
it's pretty good though alright last
last match again appreciate everyone
hanging out yeah rice come I am that
rice come just so you guys know I'm
pretty sure rice guns probably better at
Cod than I am - I like this more than
poke game for tonight um yeah so hey if
you streamed this you should definitely
let Ben stream Valkyria Chronicles it's
pretty different vehicle vehicle why
loots greedy I needed okay why did I
attempt to loot because I had no more
bullets really in that SMG which then
then I had to use my sniper to try to
pick off their next two guys and could I
have done that possibly but as some of
the people that have watched from
earlier I am terrible at sniping so I
don't know maybe I should have just
brought the sniper out and hope for a
coal at and that would have just like
probably been the way to end the stream
I'm gonna try to get to a zombie box
though is my goal here and we'll go from
there
this last round well I'll see where my
teammates go too
I think it was one at a style and last
time but anyway I can get them to go to
an island
please let's go to asylum
I'm going to asylum
looks like we decided as a team
collectively we're all just gonna oh
wait no I got one guy to follow me the
other two guys are going on their own
though this is not a good wingsuit in no
idea what little armor that was well
it's like at least two I mean I'm an
amazed with no gun why we got it
pistol just a [ __ ] show if I have to use
it okay okay
oh there's three of us here this is good
this is good
are you guys seeing this yeah all right
this is way Honda I say that right well
use it that's for sure
I'm gonna die with it to the point where
I want to use my drawn trauma kit just
because I want to get our maximum use
out of this thing
there guy guess you got a shout out to
your girlfriend there Oh
allow your one time since you've been
giving us some hot tips and a chat and
all that stuff
Oh stealthy killed someone there was
totally someone here there's another way
hander here okay so I guess it's not
that special other folks here or is it
oh there is totally you must have had
like level 5 arm or something
Oh ray gun Oh
all right boys we got the ray gun we got
the ray gun dream okay I got the ray gun
dream do we even dare to do this right
now we got the ray gun we don't need
anything else right we got a hander got
a ray gun are you guys shooting at one
key don't be just you guys though
damn we're not in the circle wait how's
the shooting do you guys think it's a
one shot
it's kind of scary there's a ray gun on
one shot am i recording yes good
stealthy good work props to you sir
yeah yeah you get that loot you deserve
it another symbol monkey
we got the double symbol monkey dream
where we're going boys where we're going
where we gone going that zombie late
let's go to zombie late
siloam looks dumb in the daytime yeah
you know can't win them all man dude
this is awesome
it's pretty good that's pretty good
and with one dude that's they're still
looting in there look at go do some
zombie action over here there should be
a box here right
technically sure pie not wasting ammo on
the holy box here hey stop it
trying to use this box that was not that
as good as the other one Oh
too much walking no action the
environment has no sound so so quiet oh
no did you hear those zombies and we're
on the outskirts of this circle um you
don't apply you always I can help you
this is my last match I know but thank
you
I'd like to Raygun someone but knowing
me I'm gonna whip like crazy and then
like cry after lot to see
and here I look gunfire shooting at
someone right now
so what do you think the person that
kills me is gonna be like oh shoot
someone has got like nuked or something
like when they pick up my ray gun
they're gonna be like whoa dude no what
are we fighting are they taking damage
doesn't look like it
does the blue line not go away unless
you kill everything the regen is one
shot up hi yeah I have to land that one
shot though but I will try I'll do my
damnedest to get this Raygun to work or
at least get a kill with it Tori my baby
Erik is growing up sometimes no vehicles
is a vehicle right there or they were
you oh there's a guy over there there's
a squad over there actually expected to
save definitely squad over there which
means that they're gonna roll up either
alongside of us very much Supply Drop
incoming
yeah there's still over there near the
water
I don't like being on the open right now
Ramla at the next circle though there's
boats there's that big Jeep or like
Humvee looking thing
no no oh gosh that was really bad
I would have preferred not to lose 14
health there or 15 have another trauma
kit though technically not really sure
why those guys cross the bridge they're
getting to the wards the middle the
circle I guess I should take the Jeep to
be closer to those guys huh
you guys taking the boat are you guys
crossing the bridge you're posting up
like to flank someone with this name but
you know
circle collapsed eminent get to safety
we're really gonna go by foot
it seems really bad
okay that team and that big truck just
left but they are fighting someone for
sure they got out of the truck
we get one kill at the Raygun I'll
consider that a win
there's definitely someone in here once
it's down
dang it I knew it it was such a bad idea
no well the dream is dead boys and girls
the dream is dead mainly because I
failed ah
alrighty I appreciate everyone tuning in
that was called duty blackout Call of
Duty's new battle royale go find some
fun stuff there's like zombies in it the
ray guns in it I'm sure there's a bunch
of other secrets you know a little
hidden bunker in Newtown all that stuff
thank you guys for you know all the
comments all the tips all the info as we
play through that I think someone had
mentioned it might be coming free the
15th of 17th I'd have to double-check
that don't quote me on that because I
didn't know that but I should have
monkey yes oh I forgot about that I had
double monkey too
anyways I didn't know he was in there
until it's too late and yeah but I
appreciate it I hope you guys have a
good rest of your day if you guys are
gonna play it check it out awesome cool
until next time
appreciate it so you guys tomorrow at 11
a.m.
[Music]